こんしゅうのざっくばらん
新手のエーアイ、JEV
Typesafe エーアイ
というベンチャー企業から、新手のエーアイが公開され、業界では大きな話題になっています。
ChatGPT、Claude、Geminiなどのエーアイモデルは、入力された質問に対して、回答を１トークンずつ生成するエーアイで、大規模言語モデル（エルエルエム）と呼ばれています。
この新手のエーアイ「JEV」は、構造化された質問に対して確率で応える「判断モデル」とでも呼ぶべきエーアイです。
例えば受け取ったメールがフィッシング詐欺かどうかを判断させる場合、メールの内容に加えて、以下のような構造化されたフォーマットで質問を投げます（実際にはJSONです）。
phishing_mail:
type: noul
instructions: このメールはフィッシング詐欺か？
これに対する返事は、
phishing_mail:
noul: 0.87
のように確率で返ってきます。
「noul」は「no」と「null」を組み合わせた造語で、「はい／いいえで答えられる主張」を表す型です。
エルエルエムでも同様の判断をしているように見えますが、実際には、１トークンずつ確率に応じて文字列を生成しているだけなので、一度ある方向に向けた文章を書き始めるとそちらに流れて書き続けてしまう傾向があり、たまに間違ったことを堂々と主張してしまうこと（ハルシネーション）があります。
１トークンごとの確率計算が積み重なってしまう結果、それが大きなノイズを発生してしまうことがあるのです。
判断モデルは、エルエルエムと違って、構造化された質問に対して確率で答えるだけなので、判断が難しい場合にはそれが明確になるし、エルエルエムのようにハルシネーションを起こす可能性がないのが大きな特徴です（もちろん、出てきた確率が間違っている可能性も十分にあるので、注意が必要です）。
試しに、TeslaのCybercabに関する報道をまとめた文章を渡し、「オーナーが年3万ドル稼げるという主張は現実的か」と聞くと、返事は「15パーセント」と返ってきました。
「規制当局はCybercabの自己認証を認めるか、免除の枠に収めるか、販売を止めるか」と聞けば、「免除:76パーセント、停止:18パーセント、認める:2パーセント」と分布で返ってきました。
興味深いのは、そのコストです。
入力に関しては、100万トークンあたり$0.04で、出力は無料です。
オープンエーアイの最新モデルジーピーティー-6 Astraが、入力$10.00/出力$50.00、もっとも低価格のジーピーティー-5.6 Lunaでも、入力$0.20/出力$1.20と（どちらも100万トークンあたり）、桁違いです。
スピードもべらぼうに速く、playground（ブラウザ上のお試し画面）で試す限り、一瞬（0.1〜0.2秒）で答えが返ってきます。
開発者自身が、これを「System One（直感的で自動的、かつ無意識に働く人間の思考モード、参照：
ダニエル・カーネマン
）」と呼んでいる通り、深く考えるのではなく直感的に答えを導き出しているようです。
入出力ともに構造化されているため、自然言語で会話できるエルエルエムと比べると不便ですが、エルエルエムを間に挟んで、「高速でハルシネーションを起こさない判断モデル」として活用するのはアリだと感じました。
JEVはオープンウェイトではないので、使える範囲は限られていますが、JEVに刺激を受けたオープンウェイトなモデルが公開されると、大量で高速な判断が必要な場面で幅広く使えると思います。
エーアイが働いている隙にする片足スクワット
座ってばかりいて仕事をしていると、つい運動不足になってしまいます。
そこで、エーアイに仕事をさせている合間に手軽にできる運動はないかと探していたところ辿り着いたのが「片足スクワット」です。
片足に全体重がかかるので、通常の両足スクワットより少ない回数で同じ負荷がかけられ、短時間（片足ずつ15回程度）で効率良く運動できます。
同じ片足スクワットでもさまざまなスタイルがあるので下の図を参照してください。
筋力が強い人は片足を浮かせてやるそうですが、私には無理です。
いずれの場合も、つま先に向かって深く沈み込むと膝に負担がかかってしまうので、かかとに体重をかけるように沈み込むのがコツです。
エーアイの危険性
つい先日、オープンエーアイとアンソロピックの両社で研究をしてきたアンソロピックの研究者（Jacob Coxon氏）が「両社は自己改善する超知能に向かって一直線に走り、私たちの命を賭けている」と述べ、会社が安全より競合に勝つことを優先していると批判して退社し、話題になりました（参照：
[EN]Anthropic safety researcher resigned with a warning about AI[/EN]
）。
それに続くかのように、今度はグーグル DeepMindの研究者（Bilal Chughtai氏）が同様の警告をして退社しました（参照：
[EN]I recently resigned from Google DeepMind, where I worked on AGI safety and alignment research[/EN]
いっぱんの人には何が起こっているか分からず、多くの人は不安に感じながらも「エーアイが人類を滅ぼすはずがない」と感じているのだろうと思います。
将来のことを予測するのは簡単ではないので、まずは現状を整理してみます。
最先端のエーアイの知能と知識は、博士課程の学生のレベルにまで達しており、オープンエーアイやエヌビディアは「AGI（汎用人工知能）を達成した」と言い始めた。
エーアイ企業は、ASI（あらゆる分野で人間をはるかに超える超知能）を誰よりも先に作る競争を繰り広げており、そのためにRSI（Recursive Self-Improvement）と呼ばれる、エーアイ自身がエーアイを改良する手法を導入し始めた。
研究者たちは、数年以内にASIが達成できると予想している。
その超知能が人間の望み通りに動く保証がなく、制御を離れて人類の永久的な無力化や死をもたらすリスクがあると多くの研究者が感じている。
そのリスクには色々なものがあるが、最も分かりやすいのは、悪意を持った人がエーアイを利用してサイバー攻撃や生物兵器の製造を行ってしまう可能性だ。
特に生物兵器は、わずかなコストで人類全体に深刻な悪影響を与えてしまう可能性がある点が問題である。
今回、アンソロピックとグーグルを辞めた二人は、こんなリスクがあるにもかかわらず、会社の利益（ASIをさいしょに作ること）を最優先し、人類全体を大きなリスクに晒していることを批判しているのです。
「そんなリスクがあるならば法律で規制すれば良い」と主張する人もいますが、簡単ではありません。
過剰な規制はイノベーションを阻害することになります。
さらに、安全保障上の観点から見て、米国だけ（もしくは西側だけ）での規制は、中国による「エーアイ覇権」を許してしまうことになりかねません。
さすがに無視できなくなった結果、アンソロピックのDario Amodeiがフロンティア・モデルのかいはつのスピードを落とすことを提案し（
[EN]We Must Pace the Frontier[/EN]
）、それにオープンエーアイのSam Altmanが賛同し（
）、グーグルのDemis Hassabisが、具体的な自主規制の枠組みを提案する（
[EN]A Framework for Frontier AI and the Dawning of a New Age[/EN]
）という流れになっています。
Bloombergの記事（
[EN]OpenAI Says It’s Working With Anthropic, Google on AI Safety[/EN]
）によると、既に三社の間での協議は始まっているそうです。
政府による規制よりも、自主規制の方が彼らにとって都合が良いのは当然ですが、中国の企業を含めずに規制をかけることに本質的な効果があるかは大いに疑問です。
中国のエーアイモデルの多くはオープンウェイトなモデルで、ファイン・チューニング（微調整）も容易なため、たとえ元のモデルに危険な質問には答えないような仕組みが入っていたとしても、ファイン・チューニングでそれを外すことは可能であり、その危険性を回避する方法はありません。
不安を掻き立てるようなことを書いてしまいましたが、これが現状であり、リスクは本物です。
だからと言って、リスクのことばかり考えていても意味がないので、必要なアンテナは張りつつ、エーアイがもたらすだろう豊かな社会に向けて自分ができることをするしかないと考えています。
ジーピーティー-6 Astra
せんしゅうも紹介したジーピーティー-6 Astraの3Dモデルの生成能力があまりにも高いので、ついにオープンエーアイのProプラン（月額100ドル）に加入してしまいました。
コーディングにも使えれば、アンソロピックのプランをMax20（月額200ドル）からMax5（月額100ドル）に減らすことも可能になるかもしれないと期待しています。
せっかくなので、Astraで作った3Dモデルをシェアするサービスを作り（
Shape Gallery
）、そこにXで募集したお題の3Dモデルを作って投稿しました。
Astraへの指示の出し方によっては、とても精密な3Dモデルを作ってくれます。
厳島神社
の場合、文化庁が公開している
詳細配置図
を活用して、正確な配置のモデルを作っています。
従来は、これを人手で作っていたので、数十万円〜数百万円はかかる作業でしたが、Astraを使うと10分程度（エーピーアイ換算で数十円）でできてしまいます。
期待よりも遥かに良いものができたのが
Breguetの懐中時計、No.1160
です。
部品表をネットで見つけ、ギアの歯の数まで正確にモデル化してくれました。
これも、人間にとっては気が遠くなるほど手間がかかる作業ですが、Astraに頼むとあっという間に行ってしまいます。
フロンティア・ラボのビジネスモデル
「フロンティア・ラボ」とは、最先端のエーアイモデル（フロンティア）を開発している研究所のことを指します。
代表格は、オープンエーアイとアンソロピックですが、彼らの特徴は、作ったモデルをエーアイサービスとして提供することを主たるビジネスとしている点です。
最先端のエーアイモデルを開発しているという意味では、グーグル、メタ、xAI（SpaceXの一部）もそうですが、彼らの場合は他に収益ビジネスがあるため、会社そのものを「フロンティア・ラボ」と呼ぶことはありません。
オープンエーアイやアンソロピックのように、他の収益源を持たない、純粋な「フロンティア・ラボ」のビジネスの収益構造は大きく分けると以下のようになっています。
売上：エーアイサービス（月額課金および従量課金）
経費：人件費、学習コスト、推論コスト
従来型のソフトウェア・ビジネスとは異なり、学習およびすいろんの際に必要なエーアイデータセンターへの投資額が莫大なのが特徴です。
1ギガワット（大型原発一基分）の電力を使うデータセンターには、概算で百億ドル（1.6兆円）のお金が必要です（電気代を含む）。
仮にこの計算能力の50パーセントを（新しいエーアイモデルを作るための）学習に、残りの50パーセントを（エーアイサービスを提供するための）推論に使い、エーアイサービスからの売上が二百五十億ドルだとすると、売上や粗利率は以下のようになります（年間ではなく、エーアイデータセンターを運営する全期間のもの）。
売上：二百五十億ドル
売上原価：五十億ドル
粗利：二百億ドル
粗利率：80パーセント
研究開発費：五十億ドル + 人件費
こんなきぼのビジネスだからこそ、トップクラスのエーアイ研究者に100万ドル（約1億6千万円）以上の給料を払う価値があるのです。
エーアイ研究者は、お金を湯水のように使って試行錯誤で次世代エーアイモデルをかいはつする必要があり、社運は彼らの手腕に大きく依存しているのです。
価格競争によりトークンあたりの価格は下がり続けていますが、同時にトークンの使用量も爆発的に増え、かつ、電力あたりのトークン生成量も増えているため、利益は十分に上がっていると見られています。
当然ですが、同じ電力からより多くのトークンを生成することができれば、売上が増えて粗利率も上がるため、推論向けに最適化された専用チップ（ASIC）が注目されているのです。
こうして見ると、フロンティア・ラボは「ソフトウェア会社」というよりも、巨額のせつびとうしを前提に高い粗利率を狙う「発電所」や「半導体工場」に近いビジネスです。
データセンターさえ作ってしまえば粗利率80パーセントというモデルは投資家にとって魅力的で、だからこそ、リスクを承知の上で巨額の資金が流れ込み続けているのです。
【参考資料】
[EN]Rittenhouse Research on X: Anthropic's compute capacity is split between training and inference[/EN]
私の目に留まった記事
[EN]Introducing the DeepMind Institute[/EN]
グーグル DeepMindが、AGI（汎用人工知能。
人間の脳が持つあらゆる認知能力を備えたエーアイ）の時代に向けて社会が答えを出すべき問題を議論するための研究組織「DeepMind Institute（DMI）」を立ち上げた、という共同創業者Shane Leggによる発表です。
上の「エーアイの危険性」で触れたように、エーアイの危険性や社会へのインパクトに注目が集まっている中、グーグルとしても受け身ではなく、自ら率先してこの問題に取り組もうという姿勢だと解釈して良いと思います。
DMIが取り組むテーマとして挙げられているのは、次のような問いです。
私たちは何に価値を置き、AGIは「人間であること」の意味をどう変えるのか
AGIシステムと、それらが形成するエージェント（自律的に行動するエーアイ）の集団を、どう安全に構築し統治するのか
社会のどの制度や政策をAGIに合わせて適応させ、あるいは根本から作り直す必要があるのか
DMIは、グーグル内部の研究者だけでなく、外部の研究者や思想家が意見を発表する場としたいとのことなので、シンギュラリティ・ソサエティとしても何か協力できないか考えてみます。
[EN]Apple Explores Enterprise AI Servers, Holding Talks With Nvidia Over NVLink Technology[/EN]
アップルがエンタープライズ市場向けに自社製のチップ（M8 Ultra）を搭載したエーアイサーバーを開発しており、そこでエヌビディアのチップ間接続技術「NVLink Fusion」の採用を検討している、というThe Information（有料）の報道を伝えるXの投稿です。
アップルがエーアイサーバーしじょうに乗り出すというのは意外ですが、新しくシーイーオーになったJohn Ternusがハード側の人であることを考えれば、100パーセント否定はできません。
アップルはいぜんから自社製チップを搭載したエーアイサーバーの構築を進めており、iPhone/iPad向けのインテリジェンスのバックエンドとして使うことを宣言していましたが、いまだにSiriは、ChatGPTと比べて大きく見劣りし、そこだけ見ると成功しているとは言い難いのが現状です。
しかし、SpaceX/xAIがエーアイサーバーの計算能力の外売りで大きな利益を上げ、かつ同時に、推論向けに最適化されたASICが盛んに開発されているのを見ると、勝負がアップルの得意とする「1ワットあたりの計算量」で決まるとすればアップルにも十分な勝算があると言えるのかもしれません。
[EN]RelateAnything: Real-Time Open-Vocabulary Relation Prediction From Any Inputs[/EN]
画像の中の物体同士の「関係」（人が犬を撫でている、コップがテーブルの上にある、など）を、あらかじめ決められた語彙に縛られず、どんな言葉でもリアルタイムに認識できる小さなエーアイモデル"RelateAnything"を発表した論文です。
巨大なVLM（視覚言語モデル。
画像と文章を同時に扱えるエーアイ）に頼らなくても、この種の問題が解けることを示した点で注目に値します。
画像から「何が」「何と」「どういう関係にあるか」を取り出す技術は、シーングラフ生成と呼ばれ、ロボットや自動運転、画像検索などの基礎になる技術です。
しかし従来のモデルは、学習時に決めた50個程度の関係語（「上にある」「持っている」など）しか扱えず、それ以外の関係を表現できないという弱点がありました。
著者は、その原因を「多様な関係語を含む検証済みのデータが存在しない」「学習語彙の外の言葉を受け付けるモデル構造がない」「語彙を広げると逆に点数が下がる評価方法しかない」という3点にあると指摘しています。
RelateAnythingは、これらを一気に解決するために作られたものです。
パラメータ数（モデルの大きさ）はわずか53M（5,300万）で、1フレームあたり20ミリ秒で処理
画像と「物体の場所（領域）」を入力すると、推論時にテキストで与えた任意の関係語彙に対してスコアを出力
物体のラベル（「犬」「人」など）を入力として必要としないため、どんな物体検出器と組み合わせても再学習が不要
19,103種類の関係語を使い、反対語（「上」と「下」など）を区別できるテキストエンコーダーで学習
あわせて、474,000枚の画像に、幾何学的に検証済みの430万件の関係（10,102種類の関係語）を付けた学習データ"RA-4M"と、語彙を広げることを正しく評価するためのベンチマーク"OV-SGG-Bench"も公開しています。
既存のオープン語彙手法と比べて平均再現率（正解の関係をどれだけ取りこぼさずに見つけられるかの指標）で2.3〜3.5倍の性能を出し、パラメータ数が2パーセント以下であるにもかかわらず、3B（30億）パラメータのVLMを上回ったとしています。
モデル、データ、ベンチマークはすべて公開されています。
注目すべきは、論文を書いたMaelic Neauがエーアイベンチャーや研究所に属さない独立した研究者である点です。
LinkedInのプロファイル
を見ると、2024年に博士号を取得したばかりのポスドクで、半年ほど日本のNII（国立情報学研究所）で働いたことがあるようです。
[EN]OpenAI Acquires Glass Imaging: AI Camera Hardware[/EN]
オープンエーアイが、スマホカメラの画質をエーアイで高める技術を持つスタートアップGlass Imagingを、三億ドル（約480億円）以上の評価額で買収した、という報道です。
Glass Imagingは、2019年にZiv AttarとTom Bishopという二人の元アップルエンジニアが創業した会社です。
Attarは2011年にLinX Imagingを創業し、2015年にアップルに買収された後、iPhone 7 Plusの「ポートレートモード（背景をぼかして人物を浮き立たせる機能）」をかいはつしたチームを率いた人物です。
Bishopも2013年から2018年までアップルで同じポートレートモードの技術に携わっていました。
同社はこれまでにシードとシリーズAで約三千万ドル（約48億円）を調達しており、今回の評価額はその約10倍にあたります。
同社の中核技術は、GlassAIと呼ばれるニューラルISP（画像信号処理プロセッサ。
カメラのセンサーから届く生データを、私たちが見る写真に変換する部分）です。
従来のカメラは、ノイズ除去、色補正、シャープ化といったしょりを段階的に行う決まったパイプラインで画像を作りますが、GlassAIはこれをまるごとニューラルネットワークに置き換え、レンズの歪み、センサーのノイズ、ブレなどを補正しながら細部を復元します。
エーアイで「それらしいピクセルを描き足す」のではなく、実際に撮影されたデータをしょりするのが特徴で、すでにHonorのスマホ「600シリーズ」のズーム撮影に採用されていました。
私はいぜんから、私たちの見ているもの、聞いているものを24時間一緒に把握してサポートしてくれる「常駐型エーアイアシスタント」の時代が来ると予測していますが、そんなデバイスにとって、少ないしょうひ電力でリアルタイムで映像をしょりすることは何よりもたいせつであり、そのための買収と見て良いと思います。
エルエルエムが画像を解釈する際には、カメラモジュールから受け取った画像を、一度、扱いやすい潜在空間（latent space）のデータに落とし込んでからしょりをしますが、その仕事をカメラモジュールそのものがすれば大幅にしょうひ電力を節約することが可能になります。
今回の買収はそこまで踏み込んでこそ意味がある話になります。
[EN]Moats & the Barbell-ification of Software[/EN]
元Facebook幹部でベンチャー投資家のMike Vernal氏が、エーアイによってソフトウェア企業の「堀（moat＝競合が真似しにくい強み）」がどう変わるのかを論じた記事です。
ソフトウェアの開発コストがエーアイによって限りなくゼロに近づいた結果、ソフトウェア業界は1990年代の新聞業界のように「巨大企業」と「個人・小規模事業」の両極端に分かれ、中間が消える、という主張です。
これは「サースビジネスの終わり」説とも繋がる話ですが、ソフトウェアがコモディティ化した結果、ソフトウェアだけで価値を生み出すのが難しくなり、マイクロソフトやグーグルのようにインフラまで構築している巨大企業は良いとして、インフラや長年の顧客との繋がりを持たないソフトウェア企業が大きなビジネスをすることは難しくなるのは当然だと思います。
逆に、個々の顧客が必要としているソフトウェアをその場で作って提供していくビジネスは、スケールはしないものの、これまで以上に伸びる可能性があります。
ただし、従来のような人月工数ではなく、マイクロ・サースのような形で、月額課金で提供するようにし、それを積み重ねていくのが良いように私には見えます。
[EN]Introducing PC-ALM, a local-learning alternative to backpropagation[/EN]
日本のエーアイスタートアップSakana エーアイが、現在のディープラーニング（深層学習。
多層のニューラルネットワークを使ったエーアイの学習手法）の土台であるバックプロパゲーション（誤差逆伝播法）を使わずに、1000層ものニューラルネットワークを学習させる新手法「PC-ALM」を発表した、という投稿です。
脳のように「局所的な仕組み」だけで学習するエーアイを目指す研究で、エーアイの学習方法そのものを見直す動きとして紹介します。
バックプロパゲーションとは、ニューラルネットワークの出力と正解とのズレ（誤差）を、出力側から入力側へと全層にわたって逆向きに伝えて、各層のパラメータを修正する仕組みで、その後のエーアイの発展の礎（いしずえ）となっている重要な技術です。
しかし、「脳はバックプロパゲーションしない」ことは多くの専門家が指摘することであり、脳が行っている「より局所的な学習法」を模倣することができれば、今よりも桁違いに電力効率の良いエーアイができてしかるべき、と考える人も多く、この「PC-ALM」もその方向を目指す研究の一つです。
Sakana エーアイは、数少ない日本のエーアイベンチャーの一つで、時々、こんな面白い論文を発表するので、注目しています。
シーティーオーのLlion Jones氏は、2017年の「Attention Is All You Need」の8人の共著者の一人であり、すべてのエルエルエムの基盤になっているTransformerを発明したチームの一員です。
すでに累計で約四億千二百万ドルを調達し、企業価値も二十七億ドルのユニコーン（十億ドル以上の企業価値を持つベンチャー企業）の一つです。
オープンエーアイ、アンソロピックなどのフロンティア・ラボが、ひたすら巨大で優秀な「超知性」作りにしのぎを削る中、彼らとは大きく異なるアプローチで新たなイノベーションを起こそうとしている面白い会社です。
[EN]MIT Report on AI Use in Teaching, Learning, and Research Training[/EN]
MITが学内の特別委員会を作り、「エーアイが大学教育をどう変えてしまったか、そしてMITはどう対応すべきか」を半年かけて調査した報告書です。
世界トップの理工系大学が、エーアイによって自分たちの教育の土台が揺らいでいることを率直に認めた点で、注目に値します。
この報告書が指摘する最も重要な点は、学びに必要な「生産的な苦労」をエーアイが取り除いてしまう危険です。
こんなことを言うと説教じみて聞こえますが、「若い頃の苦労・下働き」でしか学べないことが各業界にたくさんあります。
しかし、
学生自身が、エーアイを使うことによりその苦労をせずに成人してしまう
社会に出てから下働きをしながら仕事を学ぶ機会がエーアイにより消滅しつつある
の二つの現象が同時に起こった結果、「人が育たない社会」ができつつあるように私には見えます。
エーアイにより社会は大きく発展するのかもしれませんが、それは同時に「エーアイに頼らなければ何もできない人類」を生み出しつつあるのかもしれません。
[EN]EMS statement on recent Navier-Stokes announcement[/EN]
オープンエーアイが「ナビエ・ストークス方程式のミレニアム懸賞問題を解いた」と発表したことを受けて、ヨーロッパ数学会（EMS、ヨーロッパの数学者の学会）が公式声明を出した、という記事です。
数学者のコミュニティが、エーアイによる数学の大発見をどう受け止めているかがわかる文章なので紹介します。
ナビエ・ストークス方程式とは、水や空気などの流体の動きを記述する方程式で、「この方程式の解が常になめらかに存在するか」という問題は、100万ドルの賞金がかかった7つの「ミレニアム懸賞問題」の一つとして、長年未解決のままでした。
オープンエーアイはこの問題を、自社の数学者チームと社内のエーアイモデルの共同作業で解決したと発表しました。
EMSの声明は、まずこの発表を「数学の歴史における一つのマイルストーン」と位置づけています。
理由は、大きな未解決問題が解けたかもしれないというだけでなく、論文がオープンエーアイ名義で発表されながら、数学者とエーアイモデルの共同作業の成果であると明記されている、というその「作られ方」にある、としています。
同時に、この解決は無から生まれたものではなく、Diego Cordoba、Luis Martinez-Zoroa、Fan Zhengの3人の数学者が提案していた戦略に近いものであり、アンソロピックのLevent Alpogeと
ニューヨーク大学のTristan Buckmasterによるさいきんの進展、さらには世界中の数学者による数十年にわたる積み重ねの上に成り立っている、と念を押しています。
2022年にリリースされた当時のChatGPTは、人間とまともに会話ができるようになったという程度のものでしたが、わずか4年で数学の未解決な問題を解決するところにまで進化したことになります。
エーアイの研究者たちが、「これからはエーアイが科学を進化させる」と予想しているのは、こんな進化を目の当たりにしているからです。
[EN]GPT-6 Astra Masterclass: What Changed, What Broke, and How to Prompt Around It[/EN]
9月3日にリリースされたオープンエーアイの最新モデル「ジーピーティー-6 Astra」について、ベンチマークで何が良くなり、実際の現場で何が壊れていて、それをプロンプト（エーアイへの指示文）でどう回避するかをまとめた解説記事です。
発表直後の華やかな数字だけでなく、ユーザーが実際にぶつかっている問題を具体的に取り上げている点が貴重なので紹介します。
Astraの最大の変化は、従来のエージェントのようにエーピーアイを呼び出すのではなく、人間と同じように画面を見て、カーソルを動かし、クリックし、文字を打ってソフトウェアを操作する点です。
ベンチマークでは、ARC-AGI-3で99.9パーセント、FrontierMathの最難関ティア4で98パーセント、セキュリティ評価のExploitBenchでは前世代のジーピーティー-5.6 Solの78.5パーセントに対して100パーセントを記録しています。
実際のPC操作を測るOSWorld 2.0では、Solの65.7パーセント（所要75分）に対し、Astraは72.6パーセントを約40分で達成しました。
エーピーアイのない社内ツールや古いソフトウェアも自動化できるようになる、というのが実用面での最大の意味です。
アンソロピックがコーディング能力に力を入れているのに対して、オープンエーアイがブラウザやアプリの操作に力を入れてきた点は、差別化・使い分けという意味でもとても興味深いと感じています。
上の「ジーピーティー-6 Astra」で書いた通り、私は、Astraの一番の価値は3Dモデルの生成能力であり、コーディングに関してはアンソロピックのエーアイモデルと大きな違いはないと感じています。
[EN]Japan doesn't have a humanoid robot company worth owning but it has the entire parts list[/EN]
日本には投資対象になるようなヒューマノイド（ひとがたロボット）メーカーはないが、ヒューマノイドに必要な部品はほぼ全て日本企業が作っており、そちらの方が良いビジネスだ、と指摘する投資家の投稿です。
Goldman Sachsが作成した「ヒューマノイド産業に部品を供給する日本企業の一覧表」をもとにしています。
この表で目立つのはアクチュエーター（モーターと減速機を組み合わせた、ロボットの関節を動かす部品）の列で、Denso、Aisin、JTEKT、ハーモニック・ドライブ・システムズ、NTN、NSK、Nidec、安川電機、ファナック、三菱電機、ミネベアミツミと11社が並んでいます。
Boston DynamicsのAtlasの場合、部品コストの52パーセントがアクチュエーター、32パーセントがグリッパー（物をつかむ手の部分）で、業界全体で見てもヒューマノイド部品の売上の約58パーセントをアクチュエーターが占め、年率36パーセントで成長しているそうです。
投稿者が最も注目しているのはハーモニック・ドライブ・システムズです。
同社の四半期のエーアイロボット向け受注は12.5億円と、アナリスト予想の2倍以上で、会社側は2026年3月期のヒューマノイド向け受注を25億円、翌期にはその2〜3倍になる可能性があると説明しています。
ヒューマノイド1台には25〜50個の関節があり、TeslaのOptimusは1台に14個のハーモニックドライブ（波動歯車減速機）を使っていると言われます。
1個約$800として10万台分で約十六億ドルの需要になり、これは既存の産業用ロボット向けしじょうの5〜10倍にあたります。
同社のさくねん度の売上は595億円なので、ヒューマノイドが本格的に普及すれば既存の事業をはるかに上回る規模になります。
いぜんにも書きましたが、ひとがたロボットやドローンが必要とする部品や素材を提供するサプライチェーンを中国に代わって米国を含めた西側諸国に提供するのが、日本の製造業の維持・復活という意味で一番理にかなった戦略だと私は考えています。
とはいえ、最終製品を全く持たずに必要な部品・素材を進化させることは簡単ではないので、その辺りをこの記事にも取り上げられているトヨタ自動車あたりが引っ張ってくれることを期待します。
[EN]Korea's Trillion-Dollar Sovereign AI Investment: Nvidia Wins, Hynix Loses[/EN]
韓国が国を挙げて進める「主権エーアイ（外国に頼らず、自国でエーアイモデルとデータセンターを持つこと）」への巨額投資が、結局は最大の受益者をエヌビディアにし、韓国のメモリメーカーであるSK Hynixには負担をもたらす、と分析する半導体専門メディアSemiAnalysisの記事です。
韓国政府は2025年6月に「独自エーアイファウンデーションモデル（さまざまな用途の土台となる大型のエーアイモデル）」プロジェクトを発表し、応募した15チームの中からNaver Cloud、LG エーアイ Research、SK Telecom、NC エーアイ、Upstageの5チームを選びました。
政府の総予算は約三億五千万ドル（約560億円）で、第1ラウンドではH100（エヌビディアのエーアイ用ジーピーユー）換算で約3,000個の計算資源、データ購入費、研究者の採用費などが各チームに配分されます。
6ヶ月ごとに評価を行い、負けたチームを脱落させて勝者に資源を集中させる、勝ち抜き戦の形式です。
評価はベンチマーク（標準テストの成績）40パーセント、専門家評価35パーセント、ユーザーテスト25パーセントとされています。
記事が問題視しているのは、この選抜からMotif Technologiesが外されたことです。
Motifは従業員30人未満、調達資金千七百万ドルの小さな会社ですが、B200（エヌビディアの最新世代ジーピーユー）768個未満、費用約千五百万ドルで訓練した「Motif 3」は、中国系以外のオープンソースモデルとしては最高水準と評価されています。
それほどの成果を出した会社が、不透明な基準で脱落させられたことは、韓国のエーアイ人材が国外に流出するリスクにつながる、と記事は指摘しています。
いっぽうで、データセンター側の計画は桁違いに大きなものです。
2029年までに8.4ギガワット、2035年までに18.4ギガワットのエーアイデータセンターを建設
総投資額は九千百九十億ドル（約147兆円）
[EN]第1段階の内訳はSK Groupが5GW、GS Groupが2.4GW、Naverが1GW[/EN]
SK Telecomの2ギガワットの「エーアイファクトリー」にはエヌビディアの次世代システムVera Rubinを導入予定
Samsungも5万個以上のジーピーユーを使ったエーアイファクトリーを建設予定
エヌビディアは韓国側と五千億ドル（約80兆円）きぼのMOU（覚書。
正式契約の前段階の合意）を発表
つまり、韓国が「主権エーアイ」の名のもとに投じるお金の大半は、エヌビディア製のジーピーユーの購入に向かいます。
エヌビディアにとっては、アンソロピックとオープンエーアイという二大顧客への依存を減らせるという意味でも戦略的に価値の高いしじょうです。
さらにエヌビディアは、この深い関係を利用して、SK Hynixから有利な価格でのHBM（ジーピーユーに積まれる高帯域メモリ。
エーアイ向けジーピーユーの性能を左右する重要部品）の長期契約と2027年分の大量きょうきゅうの約束を取り付けた可能性が高い、と記事は見ています。
日本政府もエーアイ戦略に大きなお金を使うと宣言していますが、同じような状況に陥る可能性が高いので注意が必要です。
少し前のメルマガでも指摘しましたが、各国政府が独自のエーアイインフラ（ソブリンエーアイ）を育てることが、エヌビディアにとって追い風になる、というエヌビディアが狙った通りの状態が作られつつあるのです。
エーアイだけで作ったアプリ、公開3日で150万件の情報漏洩。
そうならないために気をつけること5選
エーアイツールの内製支援とセキュリティチェックを仕事にしている八木利生太郎氏が、ことし1月に起きた「Moltbook」の情報漏洩事件を題材に、ばいぶコーディングで作ったアプリに起こりがちなセキュリティの穴と、それを防ぐための5つのポイントを解説したXの投稿です。
具体的な話は記事（日本語）を読んでいただくのが一番ですが、ばいぶコーディングで作ったアプリは、手作りの飛行機みたいなもので、一応、空は飛ぶけど、安全性は全く保証されていないと認識しておく必要があります。
うっかり世界最強のWasmコンパイラを作ってしまった件
Goによく似た書きやすい構文を持ちながら、ランタイム（実行時に必ず同梱される土台部分）をほぼゼロにしたことで、極端に小さなWasm（WebAssembly。
ブラウザ上でネイティブに近い速度で動くバイナリ形式）を生成する自作プログラミング言語「Hike」のコンパイラを作った、という個人開発者の記事です。
ブラウザ向けにWasmを「気軽に」使う道を開いた点が面白く、紹介します。
Wasmは高速ですが、実際にフロントエンド開発で使おうとすると、生成されるバイナリの大きさが問題になります。
バイナリの大きさは、もちろん書いたプログラムの量にもよりますが、それ以上に効いてくるのが、どんなに短いプログラムでも必ず付いてくる「固定費」の部分です。
標準のGoでコンパイルすると、GC（ガベージコレクション。
使い終わったメモリを自動で回収する仕組み）やスケジューラが丸ごと同梱されるため、著者が試した「文字列のスライス処理、DOMの書き換え、再帰によるフィボナッチ計算」を含む小さなサンプルプログラムでも2.5〜3.0MBになり、ちょっとしたフォーム検証のために読み込むにはあまりに重すぎます。
組み込み向けのTinyGoでも30〜100KB、Rustなら5〜20KBに収まりますが、Rustは学習コストの高さが壁になります。
Hikeで同じサンプルをコンパイルすると、わずか2.56KBだったそうです。
実際に試したわけではありませんが、言語とかコンパイラ好きの私にとっては、とてもワクワクする話で、
Game80コンパイラ
を作った頃を思い出してしまいました。
質問コーナー
【質問】
堀江貴文さんのメルマガに以下の内容が含まれておりました。
一部抜粋します。
生成エーアイ「Claude」をかいはつするアンソロピック。
先日、作家らとの著作権裁判で約2400億円という巨額の和解が成立したばかりだが、その過程で公開された大量の裁判資料から明るみに出た。
まずこの裁判で咎められたのは、海賊版サイトから大量の本のデータを集めていた点である。
またソニー系の音楽出版社など35社が、歌詞を無断で学習させたとしてアンソロピックを訴えており、その裁判の行方や和解の行方が注目されているとの事です。
質問です。
「本や歌詞、メロディなど、人間が積み上げたものを学習用データとして有料提供するビジネスは成立するでしょうか。
もし成立するなら、作者や作曲者の価値はこんごどのように変わるとお考えですか？
」
《回答》
大量のデータを著作権をクリアにした上でエーアイラボが処理しやすい形に整理して提供するのであれば、良いビジネスになると思います。
学習用データの整備をビジネスにした代表例がScale エーアイで、画像や文章へのラベル付け、人間によるフィードバックデータ（RLHF用）の作成、モデルの評価などを大手エーアイラボ向けに請け負い、2025年6月にメタから百四十三億ドル（2兆円超）を受け取って、実質的に買収されました。
著作物そのもののライセンスという意味では、RedditやNews Corpがエーアイラボと結んだ契約や、今回のアンソロピックの和解（1冊あたり約3,000ドル）が、「対価を払えば使える」という相場を作りつつあります。
作者や作曲者の価値については、人間の読者や聴衆に向けた本来のしじょうで決まるという構造は変わらないと思います。
そこにエーアイ向けのライセンス収入という第二の収益源が加わりますが、一作品あたりの単価は、上の和解額が示すように、作者が期待するほど大きくはならないでしょう。
むしろ、エーアイが大量のコンテンツを生み出す時代には、「この人が作った」というブランドや、ファンとの直接の繋がりを持つ作者の価値が相対的に上がると考えています。
【質問】
いぜんから中島さんが、UIEvolution（Xevo）でトヨタと仕事をされた経験を踏まえて、トヨタはソフトウェアを外注し、車載器メーカーやその下請けに仕様書を渡す形で開発してきた、と書かれていたことが印象に残っています。
最近、酒井崇男さんの動画をきっかけに、トヨタのChief Engineer制度や製品開発について調べているのですが、そこで少し疑問が生まれました。
酒井さんの説明では、Chief Engineerが顧客に提供する価値を考え、それを車両全体の機能へ落とし込みながら各部門を統合して製品を成立させています。
また、初代プリウスなどを見ると、エンジン、モーター、バッテリーなどの高度な協調制御もトヨタ自身が深く開発しており、単純に「ソフトウェアを作れない会社」とも思えなくなりました。
そこで、中島さんが「トヨタはソフトウェアが弱い」と指摘されているのは、主にUIEvolution時代に関わったナビ、コネクテッド、車載ユーアイなどの領域なのでしょうか。
つまり、トヨタは車両制御のような「クルマを成立させるソフトウェア」には強い内製能力を持ついっぽう、ユーザーが直接触れるソフトウェアを一つの製品として作り、ユーアイ/ユーエックスを継続的に改善していく能力が弱かった、という理解なのでしょうか。
もしそうだとすると、トヨタにはChief Engineerを中心に商品価値を統合する強い製品かいはつの仕組みがあるのに、なぜナビや車載ユーアイ、コネクテッドではその強さが十分に発揮されなかったのかも気になります。
当時はそうした領域が、走りや燃費、品質などと同じレベルの重要な商品価値として、Chief Engineerを中心とした製品企画の中に十分組み込まれていなかったのでしょうか。
UIEvolutionを通じて実際にトヨタと仕事をされた中島さんから見て、この整理がどの程度実態に近いのか伺いたいです。
参考までに、今回この疑問を持つきっかけになった酒井崇男さんの記事と動画を添付します。
酒井崇男さん「トヨタ チーフエンジニアの仕事（英語版）向け寄稿文」
参考動画
《回答》
ご指摘の整理は、ほぼ実態に近いと思います。
私から見て、トヨタ自動車の問題は大きく分けて二つありました。
一つ目は、車載器（カーナビを搭載するコンピュータ）を外部から調達する部品として扱う開発体制そのものにあります。
カーナビ、運転補助、エンターテイメント、スマートフォンとの接続などが自動車を運転するユーザーの体験としてますます重要になっているにもかかわらず、カーナビがオプションだった頃の発想でものづくりをしていました。
そのため、（スピードメーター等が表示されている）ダッシュボードとの一体感が欠如し（別々の会社が作っていました）、ユーザー体験そのもののプライオリティも、「運転のし心地」「乗り心地」などと比べるとはるかに低かったのです。
二つ目は、第一線で働くエンジニアたちのマインドセットを経営陣が全く理解していなかった点です。
副社長クラスの人と、たまたま話がエンジニアのインセンティブの話になった時、私がストックオプションの話をしたところ、全く理解してもらえませんでした。
日本の大企業でしか働いたことのない人たちが、ソフトウェア・ベンチャーで働くエンジニアにとってストックオプションの存在がどのくらい重要かを理解するのが難しいことは分かりますが、副社長クラスの人がなんの勉強もしていなかったことに私はショックを受けました。
2019年ごろの話なので、少しは改善したかもしれませんが、この二つはどちらも「企業カルチャー」そのものに根付くものなので、簡単ではないと思います。
【質問】
エヌビディアのジェンスン・フアン氏がオープンエーアイのAGI達成を祝福し、他の識者からも同様の声が上がっていますが、本当にAGI（汎用人工知能）は実現したのでしょうか？
また、こんご、仮にどこか1社がさいしょにASI（人工超知能）を実現し、それをしばらく独占し続けた場合、他社と圧倒的な差がつき、市場や技術のすべてを獲得して「圧勝」するのではないかと思います。
この点について、中島先生の見解をお聞かせください。
《回答》
AGIもASIも定義が曖昧なので、「AGIが実現したか？
」ではなく「AGIと呼ぶに値するほどの進化を遂げたか？
」と考えた方が良いと思います。
ジェンスン・フアン氏は、Astraにはそれだけの価値があると認めたのです。
もし、どこか1社がASIと呼べる人工知能を実現し、他社が追いつけないとしたら、それは大きな差別化になり、他社を圧倒するどころか、世界の覇者になってしまう可能性すらあります。
しかし、今の状況を見る限り、数社が先端を走り続ける可能性が高いと思います。
また、そんな時代には、単にモデル間の戦いではなく、インフラ力（総計算量）の戦いになっている可能性も十分にあるので、そこは意識しておくと良いと思います。
【質問】
最近、エーアイの普及によって既存産業のコスト構造や利益率そのものが大きく変わる可能性に興味を持っています。
例えば先日、Minerva Intelligenceという企業が「会計事務所を買収し、業務をエーアイネイティブに作り直すことで営業利益率を5パーセントから70パーセントまで改善した」と発信していました。
もちろんこの数字自体の持続性などは別として、エーアイ企業をゼロから作るのではなく、すでに顧客や売上が存在する既存企業にエーアイを導入することで、人間はより付加価値の高い仕事に集中し、企業全体の生産性や利益率を大きく引き上げるという考え方は、中島さんがいぜんからお話しされていることにも近いように感じました。
投資家として考えた場合、こうした「エーアイによって既存のコスト構造や利益率が大きく変わる企業」は、こんご非常に面白い投資対象になるのではないかと思っています。
中島さんが現在、このような観点から具体的に注目されている企業や業界はありますでしょうか？
また、すでにエーアイによる生産性向上が業績に現れ始めている企業があれば、ぜひ教えていただきたいです。
《回答》
具体的に注目している企業はありませんが、このケースのように、既存の会社が自ら生まれ変わるのではなく、企業買収のような形での変化の方が可能性は高いと思います。
その場合には、買収される会社の株ではなく、買収する側の株を持っておくべきだと思います。
【質問】
Rivianのシーイーオー RJ Scaringeについてどの様な印象を持たれていますか？
イーロン・マスクやスティーブ・ジョブズが持っていたカリスマ性を感じますか？
《回答》
彼にはそれほどのカリスマ性は感じませんが、イーロン・マスクに匹敵するようなカリスマ性を持つ人は数えるほどしかいないので、特にネガティブに考える必要もないと思います。
エヌビディアのジェンスン・フアン氏は、素晴らしい経営者ですが、特別なカリスマ性を持っているとは思いません。
【質問】
過去のイノベーションには研究者の遊び心や失敗（島津製作所でノーベル賞を取った田中さん等）から生まれているものが多いと感じています。
近年、エーアイを活用して自動自律実験環境内で新しい薬や材料研究がなされていると思いますが、エーアイにより意図的な失敗やユーモアを実験に加えることはできるのでしょうか。
多くのパターンから可能性の高い実験計画は描けると思うのですが、奇想天外な発想はエーアイでできるのか中島さんの見解を伺いたいです。
《回答》
エーアイに「遊び心」があるとは思いませんが、エーアイはパラメータを少しずつ変えながら膨大な組み合わせを試すなどがとくいなので、そのアプローチの結果、新たなものを発見する可能性が高いと思います。
数学での発見が先行しているのはデジタルの世界だけで実験が可能なためですが、実際の実験装置とエーアイを繋ぐようになれば、化学や医学の分野での発見・発明も加速すると期待しています。
【質問】
エーアイ前提の社内データレイクハウス（BigQuery想定）と、その上で動くMA/SFA/CRM等をエーアイで自社かいはつするPJを進めています。
裏側のエーアイモデルは変化が激しいため、柔軟に切替できる構成にしたいと考えています。
本番へのOpenRouter組み込みを検討しましたが、開発現場から以下3点の懸念が挙がり、「検証はOpenRouter、本番は各モデルと直接契約」が良いという意見が出ています。
データ保持期間：直契約なら即時削除設定可、OpenRouterは30日固定で変更不可
DPA：データ利用制限の契約が結べるか不透明。
結べないと監督義務違反のリスク
監査ログ：OpenRouter経由だと閲覧不可
直契約が難しい安価な中国製モデル等は本番採用を諦めることになり、片手落ちな気もしています。
前提：売上100億円、従業員100名前後のBtoB中心のIT企業。
規模的にBigQueryを想定。
ご意見・具体的な設計アドバイスをいただけますと幸いです。
《回答》
3つの懸念はいずれももっともで、直接契約にすれば解消できます。
ソフトウェアさえしっかりと作ってあれば、モデルの切り替えはそれほど難しくないので、OpenRouterは使わずに、社内で作ったモジュールを使って、モデルを切り替えるようにするのが良いと思います。
ちなみに、その際には、社内のサーバーにおいたオープンウェイトなモデルも走らせられるようにしておくと、将来「社内の機密データをエーアイサービスには送りたくない」となった際に切り替えられるので良いと思います。
中国製モデルの多くはオープンウェイトなので、この形なら社内で安全に使えます。
【質問】
先日、GO、Waymo、日本交通が、2027年中に東京で完全無人のロボタクシー商用化を目指す。
とのニュースを見ました。
なぜ日本ではタクシー会社が間にいるのでしょうか。
私はロボタクシーの普及によって、現在の1/10程度の価格でタクシー移動が可能になると思っていました。
しかし、Waymoが直接サービスを開始しないと、「ロボタクシーには乗れるけれど、料金は既存のタクシーと同価格」ということになりかねないと危惧しております。
中島さんは本件についてどう考えておられるでしょうか。
《回答》
Uberの日本進出の件でも分かる通り、日本社会はこの手のビジネスの変化に対して保守的で、しばしば社会主義的な動きをします。
まずはタクシー会社が自動運転車を運行する、という形でスタートするのはいかにも日本的で、「これでは自動運転車にしたところで値段は安くならない」という懸念はもっともです。
ちなみに、前回の出張で羽田空港までUberを使いましたが、TeslaのModel Yで迎えにきてくれた上に、タクシーと同じく都内からの定額運賃が適用され、とても気分が良かったです。
台数も増えたようで、ようやくUberも市民権を得たように思います。
自動運転車に関しても、時間はかかるとは思いますが、最終的には市民権を得ると期待しても良いと思います。
日本の場合は、ドライバー不足と高齢化が一番の問題なので、たとえ値段が下がらなくとも導入する価値があると思います。
【質問】
中島さんがいぜんからおっしゃっているように、エーアイの本質的なインパクトは、単なる既存業務の効率化ではなく、これまで存在しなかったアプリやサービス、じゅようが新しく生まれる点にあるのではないかと感じています。
たとえば、エーアイによって個人が自分専用のアプリを作れるようになることなどは、まさにその一例だと思っています。
ただそこから投資先を具体的にしていく段階で、どの情報源や人物などにベンチマークを置いていくといいのかなどがイマイチ自分の中で掴めておらず、何かヒントになる考え方などをお聞きできると嬉しいです。
《回答》
私が普段参考にしているものをいくつか挙げます。
Podcastであれば、
All-in Podcast
がお勧めです。
人物としては、さいきんは、
Gavin Baker
Dylan Patel
の発言に注目しています。
VCとしては、
a16z
が有益な情報を発信しています。
【質問】
手持ちのドル資金によゆうがあるため、オルカン（全世界株式）を中核とするポートフォリオにおいて、半導体製造装置最大手Applied Materials（AMAT）をサテライト投資として組み込もうかと考えています。
というのも、AMATはエーアイという「現代のゴールドラッシュ」において、金を掘るプレイヤーではなく、最も高度な「ツルハシ（最先端の半導体製造装置）」を独占的に供給する元売り企業であると考えたためです。
ただいっぽうで、どのタイミングで購入するかは非常に悩ましく思っています。
中島さんであれば、どのような指標を参考にして購入するかを参考までに教えていただきたいです。
《回答》
Applied Materialsの株は持っていませんが、とても良い会社だと思います。
買うべきタイミングを見極めるのはとても難しいので、私は気に入った会社は、思いついた時に少し株を入手し、その後「自分ごと」と感じられるようになったら、ドルコスト平均法で数ヶ月にわたって少しずつ購入します。
【質問】
[EN]Anthropicが先日公開した「Scenarios for our Economic Future」を読みました。
[/EN]
この記事では、エーアイの普及によってジーディーピーそのものが大きく成長する可能性があるいっぽうで、その成長によって生まれた富の分配先が「労働」から「資本」へ移っていく可能性が示されています。
個人的には、この話を読んで、現在はいぱーすけーらーが行っている巨額のエーアイインフラ投資ともつながるように感じました。
これまでは企業が生産能力を高めるために「人」を雇うことが重要でしたが、エーアイ時代には、データセンター・半導体・電力などのエーアイインフラに投資することで、より大きな生産能力を得られるようになる可能性があります。
そう考えると、投資家としてはアマゾン、グーグル、マイクロソフト、メタなど、エーアイ時代の「生産設備」を大量に保有するはいぱーすけーらーの株を持つことも、この大きな流れに乗る一つの方法なのかなと考えています。
中島さんは、アンソロピックが示しているような「エーアイによって労働から資本へリターンが移っていく世界」を前提とした場合、投資家としてどのような戦略・方向性でポートフォリオを考えるのが良いと思いますか？
はいぱーすけーらーを保有するのか、それともエヌビディアのような半導体企業、電力・データセンター・ネットワークなどのインフラ側を保有するのか、中島さんの考えをお聞きしたいです。
《回答》
一番素直に考えると、マイクロソフト、グーグル、アマゾンなどのはいぱーすけーらーが一番堅いです。
それに続いて、エヌビディア/AMD/Broadcom、ASML/TSMCなどが続きます。
私はいずれの企業の株も長期保有で、ポートフォリオの中で大きな比重を占めています。
【質問】
半導体関連株はここ数年かなり注目されており、エーアイの進化に伴ってこんごも半導体じゅようはさらに拡大していくと考えられていると思います。
特にエーアイ関連では、こんごもデータセンターやジーピーユーなどへの投資が続くことで、半導体関連企業の業績や株価も引き続き上昇すると見る方が多い印象です。
いっぽうで、私は少し別のリスクもあるのではないかと考えています。
中国の半導体企業もここ数年でかなり技術力を高めており、最先端半導体はともかく、汎用的な半導体やメモリについては、中国国内での生産能力が高まることで、こんご価格が下落する可能性があるのではないかと思っています。
特に気になっているのが、中国の半導体自給率が高まった場合の影響です。
例えば、サムスンやSK hynixなどのメモリメーカーは中国向けの販売比率も高く、中国が政策的にメモリの国産化を進め、これまで海外から輸入していた汎用メモリを国内企業で賄えるようになれば、世界的なメモリ需要や価格形成にも影響が出るのではないかと考えています。
そうなると、エーアイ向けの最先端メモリ（HBMなど）のじゅようは引き続き強くても、汎用メモリの価格下落によって、サムスンやSK hynixなどの業績や株価には下押し圧力がかかる可能性もあるのではないでしょうか。
つまり、「エーアイによって半導体じゅようが拡大する」という大きな流れがあるいっぽうで、「中国の半導体自給率向上によって、最先端以外の半導体・メモリが供給過剰になり、価格が下落する」という逆方向の力もあるのではないか、というのが私の考えです。
この点について、中島さんはどのようにお考えでしょうか？
《回答》
中国の件は、政治も絡むので先を読むのがとても難しいと感じています。
少し前に、アップルは中国のメーカーからメモリを購入する許可を米国政府に求めましたが、まだ決着がついていません。
その決着次第で、メモリ関連株の株価は大きく動くと思いますが、それを予想して投資するのは私のスタイルとはマッチしません。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。